Constantemente nos piden nuestra opinión
¿Qué equipo crees
que ganará el Super Tazón?
¿Quién vistió mejor en la alfombra roja?
¿Por quién vas a votar para alcalde?
Las encuestas de opinión
pública están por doquier.
Los tomadores de decisiones
en el gobierno estadounidense
han confiando en las encuestas
de opinión desde hace tiempo
para las elecciones y
legislaciones importantes.
El problema es que la opinión
pública no es fácil de seguir
y, a menudo, ni siquiera es correcta.
En 1948, el Chicado Daily Tribune
publicó un titular hoy famoso:
"Dewey vence a Truman",
lo resaltaron en grandes letras en negrita,
en blanco y negro.
El problema fue que
Dewey no había vencido a Truman.
El Tribune se basó en las encuestas
para hacer sus conclusiones.
¡Uy!
Esto pasa todo el tiempo porque
las encuestas de opinión
o bien son inexactas o erróneas.
Entonces, ¿por qué son erróneas?
¿Y por qué seguimos usándolas?
Primero, empecemos con
un término importante:
muestra.
Una muestra es el grupo de personas
que responde a preguntas
en una encuesta de opinión.
La calidad de una encuesta yace
principalmente en su muestra,
y una muestra puede ser mala
en algunas formas cruciales.
Puede ser demasiado pequeña
demasiado angosta
o la encuesta misma puede
ser demasiado difícil.
Las encuestas que son demasiado pequeñas,
son malas por razones obvias.
Aunque no es posible preguntar
a todos y cada uno de
los estadounidenses su opinión,
entre más gente se encueste,
más precisa será una predicción.
Las encuestas que
son demasiado angostas,
que sólo encuestan a cierto
tipo de gente o de preguntas
también son malas.
Consideren una encuesta sobre si
la papa es la mejor verdura
en EE.UU. o no.
Si sólo encuestan a
personas en Idaho,
donde la papa es
el alimento del estado,
la probabilidad es que obtengan
una respuesta muy diferente
de la que obtienen al encuestar
a personas de Nuevo México,
donde el frijol es
la verdura del estado.
Conseguir el tipo correcto de
diversidad en una muestra
significa asegurarse
que la muestra tenga
un rango de edades,
razas,
géneros
y regiones geográficas
por sólo nombrar algunas.
Al final, las encuestas que son
muy difíciles tampoco dicen mucho.
Si se pregunta a la gente
su opinión sobre cosas
de las que no tienen
conocimiento previo,
los resultados no tendrán sentido.
En tal caso mejor sacude
una Bola 8 Mágica de la fortuna
No sólo la gente encuestada
puede provocar sesgo,
el encuestador también
es parte del problema.
A eso se le llama
sesgo del encuestador.
El sesgo del encuestador
se trata de todo el efecto
que la persona que pregunta
tiene sobre la muestra.
En general, a los humanos
no nos gusta la confrontación.
A la gente le preocupa que puedan
verse mal por sus respuestas
Por lo tanto, vemos que
la gente tiende a dar
respuestas socialmente deseables,
no necesariamente
su honesta opinión,
porque no quieren aparecer
como despiadados
racistas
o intolerantes.
Y la forma en que expresamos
las preguntas también cuenta.
Cuando las encuestas inclinan a
adrede a un lado u otro las respuestas
a eso se le llama "push poll" o
encuesta tendenciosa
porque lleva a la gente
a contestar de cierto modo.
"¿Votaría por el candidato Smith?"
Es una pregunta
perfectamente normal.
"¿Votaría por el candidato Smith
si supiera que roba a
los ciudadanos mayores?"
es una encuesta tendenciosa.
Entonces, si las encuestas
están abiertas
a todo tipo de manipulaciones
e imprecisiones,
¿por qué se usan tanto?
A pesar de sus fallas, las encuestas
de opinión nos ofrecen
una cierta idea de los
pensamientos y ánimos
de grandes grupos de personas.
Ofrecen a los políticos la oportunidad
de aprobar legislaciones
que creen que la mayoría
de estadounidenses apoyará.
Les sirven a los seguidores
de moda en la tele
saber qué estrella vistió
mejor en la alfombra roja.
Por último, nos hace a nosotros,
los encuestados,
sentir como si nuestra voz
hubiese sido escuchada.
Así, la próxima vez que recibas
una llamada pidiendo tu opinión,
o si ves una encuesta en línea,
date tiempo para pensar
quién está preguntando
y del porqué de sus preguntas.
Por tanto, toma la encuesta
y sus resultados
con pinzas
o hazlo con precaución.